NETFLIX ANIME
We managed to get some questions answered
by the production staff of Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway too!
Here I go!
Ta-da!
Hi! It’s me, N-ko!
This may seem random,
but have you already seen the latest in the Gundam series,
Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway?
Soon after being released in theaters in Japan,
it became the biggest hit of all Gundam movies!
It’s a long awaited movie for all Gundam fans!
Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway is streaming
only on Netflix outside of Japan.
Actually, I hadn't properly watched much Gundam until now.
I’m definitely interested,
but since there are so many titles,
I have no idea where to start.
I was really worried I wouldn't be able to understand Hathaway,
having not seen the previous titles.
But when I asked the hardcore Gundam fans at Netflix,
I found out that Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway can be enjoyed
even if you haven’t watched any of the previous Gundam titles!
However, if you’ve seen the previous titles, it'll be even more fun to watch!
I will share which Gundam titles you should watch before watching the movie,
and some basic information for you to fully enjoy it.
I'm a Gundam newbie myself,
so bear with me
if I don’t have the details or my explanation is incorrect.
Let’s introduce some titles!
Here I go!
Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway is a three part series.
The one that’s streaming right now is part one.
It’s set in the year U.C. 0105.
U.C. stands for Universal Century, a timeline in the Gundam series.
When the total population on Earth went over nine billion,
the Earth Federation decided to move people out to space.
That’s when the calendar year was changed to the Universal Century.
However, only the privileged,
such as high officials of the Earth Federation,
or the rich, are allowed to live on Earth.
In addition, the Earth Federation
uses a police force called “Man Hunters”
to hunt down any illegal residents on Earth,
and exile them back into space.
The anti-Federation group called “Mafty”
takes a stand against the Earth Federation.
They fight against the Earth Federation,
with the goal to force all humanity from Earth into outer space.
And the leader of Mafty,
who goes by the name of Mafty Navue Erin,
is the protagonist of this movie, Hathaway Noa.
He is the son of Bright Noa, who commanded the protagonist
and his team in the very first Gundam series,
and is praised as the hero of the Earth Federation in this era.
When I think of Gundam,
I think of it as a simple robot anime,
but isn't this setting quite detailed?
During the film, Mafty, aka Hathaway, has an encounter
with Earth Federation officer Colonel Kenneth Sleg,
and develops a friendship with him.
Kenneth is assigned as the commander of the Mafty Annihilation Unit.
In other words, he’s Hathaway’s arch rival.
Of course, Hathaway is hiding his identity from Kenneth.
In addition,
he meets a mysterious girl named Gigi Andalucia
around the same time he meets Kenneth.
Hathaway is attracted to Gigi's mature yet childlike mysterious personality.
However, Gigi uses her mysterious powers to detect that Hathaway is Mafty.
Hathaway is wary, but attracted to Gigi at the same time.
On top of that, Kenneth gets involved,
and turns it into a love triangle!
Suspenseful and heart-stopping relationships intermixed with friends and foes.
That's another charm of Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway.
Many may think of Gundam as a show about robots, mecha, and mobile suits,
but in reality,
it also has rich and deep human drama.
It's also about the government,
or about politics.
It really matches the current zeitgeist.
I think the story covers all of society.
Especially with Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway,
I felt like I was on a trip.
It started with a scene that made me feel like I was on a luxury cruise ship,
and it takes place somewhere Japanese people would consider “abroad.”
The movie gave me the feeling of being on a trip.
It was a beautiful movie to watch,
and it was an interesting title, even without any knowledge about Gundam.
Now,
speaking of the Gundam series,
there are lots of titles.
But if we were to categorize them,
there are series set in the Universal Century timeline,
and those that are not.
Those are the two main categories.
Titles set in the Universal Century timeline
are all connected as part of one history.
Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway is part of
the Universal Century timeline.
That means if you watch the past U.C. titles,
you’ll know all the history leading up to Hathaway.
You can enjoy this movie on its own,
but when you find out where it stands in the history of the series,
it’s even more entertaining.
This is one of the charms of Gundam.
According to the Gundam lovers at Netflix,
the U.C. Gundam titles that come before Hathaway
are as follows.
"Mobile Suit Gundam"
"Mobile Suit Zeta Gundam"
"Mobile Suit Gundam ZZ"
"Mobile Suit Gundam: Char's Counterattack"
"Mobile Suit Gundam Unicorn"
"Mobile Suit Gundam Narrative"
"Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway"
As you can see, there are many more Gundam titles
prior to Hathaway.
And Hathaway appears in some of them as a child.
Now, these two shows are the ones you ought to watch
before you watch Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway.
The first one is Mobile Suit Gundam.
It’s the very first Gundam series,
and it’s also referred to as "First Gundam."
It takes place in U.C. 0079.
One of the space colonies, Side 3, where the immigrants live,
declares itself as the Principality of Zeon,
calling for independence from the Earth Federation.
This is the start of the One Year War.
The protagonist Amuro Ray gets mixed up in this war.
Bright Noa is the leader of Amuro’s team and the Captain of the White Base.
He's Hathaway's father.
By the way, his mother is Mirai Yashima, the helmsman of White Base.
That means this is the story where Hathaway’s parent’s meet.
This is the origin of the Gundam series,
and the basis for the whole Universal Century timeline.
So let’s start by watching this series.
By the way, if you search Mobile Suit Gundam on Netflix,
you might get both the TV series and the three-part movie series in some regions.
But I recommend watching the movies since they're shorter.
But to meet the time frame,
some amazing scenes have been cut from the movie version.
So if you are curious, please watch the TV series.
The next one is Mobile Suit Gundam: Char's Counterattack.
It was released over 30 years ago, in 1988,
but Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway
is a direct sequel to this movie.
It involves the final battle between protagonist Amuro Ray
and his rival, Char Aznable.
Hathaway appears as a 13-year-old in this movie.
What did Hathaway see and feel during the war?
Mobile Suit Gundam: Char's Counterattack scenes are mentioned
in Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway as well,
so if you watch it,
you’ll be able to follow the story more smoothly.
The Universal Century Gundam titles,
including Mobile Suit Gundam and Mobile Suit Gundam: Char's Counterattack,
can all be found on Netflix.
Please watch these titles
before you watch Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway,
and prepare yourself!
Of course, it’s all right to get hooked
on other Gundam titles after you watch Hathaway too.
Now, all I’ve been doing so far is talk about the storyline,
but aren’t you curious about Gundam mobile suits too?
I am not an expert on robots,
so I haven’t mentioned them so far,
but that’s one essential part of the Gundam franchise.
In Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway,
Xi Gundam appears as Hathaway’s Gundam.
Its biggest characteristic
is that it can fly freely on Earth.
Because of Earth’s gravity,
previous Gundam models could jump using a booster,
but they were unable to fly at high speed for a long period at a time.
To fly, they have to transform into waverider form like the Zeta Gundam,
or to go onto a transport carrier.
However, the Xi Gundam has
a Minovsky Flight Unit installed,
allowing it to fly freely at high speed through the air,
even with gravity.
The Minovsky Flight Unit is only installed
in the Xi Gundam
and its rival machine, Penelope.
You can’t blink during these two Gundams' high-speed air combat.
Since this Xi Gundam can fly,
its straight lines are really cool.
I would say that overall, it’s like...
swoosh, swoosh, swoosh!
I think its body design is really cool.
I thought it was a very distinctive mobile suit design
where you can guess it instantly
if it were to appear as a silhouette.
I’ve been talking about Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway
and the Gundam series so far,
but now I have something special!
We were able to get an email interview
with Ogata, the producer of the film.
Thank you very much, Producer Ogata.
He shared highlights and behind-the-scenes stories for a Gundam newbie like me.
I would now like to share that with you.
"Simply put, what kind of a girl is Gigi Andalucia?"
"She seemed mature and childish at the same time."
"She is hard to figure out. She truly was a femme fatale."
"Please tell us the story behind building the character."
"For men, Gigi is a mysterious woman"
"who they can never figure out."
"In terms of character, she contains several characteristics of women"
"that appear in the works of Yoshiyuki Tomino."
"In creating the film, I couldn’t avoid Quess,"
"who appeared in Mobile Suit Gundam: Char's Counterattack."
"She had a huge effect on creating Gigi’s character in this piece."
So about what Producer Ogata said about Gigi
being a mysterious being
whom men can never comprehend...
This really is clear when you watch the movie.
The movie is mainly from Hathaway’s perspective,
and so from Hathaway’s perspective, Gigi is seen as a mysterious woman,
and he can’t comprehend her.
It's really beautifully and well portrayed.
It made me think maybe women are mysterious beings that men will never understand.
"If there are any highlights from the production team side"
"where fans could declare themselves as true Gundam fans"
"when they notice this part in the movie, please let us know."
"The cockpit in the Messer is located in its head."
"This is to express the fact that the Messer’s design is derived"
"from the Sazabi in Mobile Suit Gundam: Char's Counterattack."
Gundam lovers should remember these facts!
"Which Gundam title is the most popular among the production crew?"
"We understand it's hard to narrow it down,"
"but if you have to just pick one, which one would it be?"
"Each member of the production crew is different,"
"but many of us, including myself, love Char's Counterattack."
I’m definitely planning to watch Char's Counterattack,
which is closely related to Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway.
"The main theme, 'Senko,' performed by Alexandros"
"is such a great fit for the movie."
"I felt it was part of the charm of the movie."
"What kind of request did you make"
"when you asked them to write the music?"
"This movie is the first movie of the series,"
"and the fact that it’s the brightest moment of Hathaway’s life,"
"when Alexandros first offered the music,"
"it sounded much heavier and darker,"
"so we had them change it to music"
"that’s up-tempo and fast, and could be used as an opening for a TV series."
"For the lyrics, we requested Yohei Kawakami read the novel in detail,"
"and come up with a theme song that went along with Hathaway’s life."
"Their agent is a huge Gundam fan,"
"and their label RX-Records' "RX","
"came from Gundam."
"They happily accepted our offer"
"and also participated in several promotions."
That music could certainly be an opening song for a TV series.
It was very refreshing.
I would also like to hear the heavier and darker music.
Thank you for taking the time to answer all the questions despite your busy schedule.
Now, before seeing Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway,
I was thinking that Gundam seemed hard to comprehend and get into,
but the more I learn about it, the more it opens my eyes.
I now want to watch more Gundam titles!
How about all Gundam fans as well as non-Gundam fans
watch Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaway?
It’s a three-part series,
so I can’t wait to watch its sequels, part two and part three!
I would be so happy if you could write your opinion in the comments section!
I’ll see you again in the next video!
See you!